all right so i'm super excited about
this i just heard about this yesterday
it sounds like the trailer or the teaser
trailer or the pre-teaser trailer or
something like that of star wars episode
7 the force awakens is coming out on
thanksgiving weekend i just heard about
this i have incredibly incredibly high
hopes if you know anything about me at
this point you know that i love star
wars i believe in the force as much as i
believe in almost anything else there's
something out there you can use it for
good you can use it for bad but it kind
of exists and it's there and it binds us
that whole thing that obi-wan said in
his house on tatooine uh episode four
the original uh anyway i'm really
excited about this and yes look
everybody i can already see you see what
happens on social media already
everybody's already saying oh the
prequels all sucked blah blah blah for
the record i did not dislike the the
prequels yes phantom menace was a bit it
was a mess the pod racing was a little
too much the kid was kind of annoying
okay okay clone wars kinda the second
one kinda came around started building a
bigger story about what was happening
and i thought revenge of the sith was
dark and it could have yeah could have
been a little bit darker but it was
pretty solid as a movie anyway bringing
j.j abrams who did star trek and has
done a gajillion other great things i'm
incredibly excited about this i think
it's going to be phenomenal i'm looking
forward to just just the 90 seconds just
give me a little tease of something we
know that the old guys carrie fisher
mark hamill harrison ford chewbacca
whatever that guy's name is i forget
that they're all going to be in it um
and i think it's going to be fun to see
and it's always look some people people
are always upset you you can never go
back to the past that's why we all have
things from our childhood that always
seem better to us you know i did a thing
a 140 last week about video games about
how they seem so much better in my
childhood than they seem now like that
it's hard to beat that nostalgia
quotient somebody on twitter gave me a
great phrase for that that you just
can't go back you can't what was that
woody allen movie uh midnight in paris
we all kind of want to think of a time
that existed as if it was so great
and time just kind of marches on anyway
so i'm not going to prejudge the thing i
will post-judge it
and of course you know some people are
going to hate it no matter what some
people are going to love it no matter
what oh there's too much cgi too much
graphics we want the old school stuff i
have a feeling jj's going to figure out
how to do it all pretty perfectly so
force awakens trailer coming out and yes
i will comment on it once i see it